stephen wolfram is one of the most
inventive and prolific people on the
planet he's the rare trifecta of a
computer scientist
a physicist and a business person who
founded wolfram research
designed mathematica which is a program
that almost each
mathematician physicist uses especially
engineers as well as wolf from alpha
which powers
siri this may be the most wide-ranging
interview with steven
that exists we talk about aliens or
alien life and the communication with
them
cryptocurrency the nature of infinity
and the reality to
infinity he even gives a template as to
how to build your own theory of
everything which
separates him from others because most
of the time people are proposing
their own theory of everything keep in
mind that the podcasts on theories of
everything
tend to be a bit more abstruse and
technical
if you don't follow some of the jargon
that's okay the point is that you stick
through anyway till the end
to get an overview and then it's in the
re-watching that the actual
information is gleaned this was a live
stream which is now reposted with better
video
and audio and while i was live streaming
at the end i gave some of my thoughts
which i've
included at the end of this as well they
include objections that i may have or
questions that i'd like you to explore
and perhaps you can give me
your thoughts your answers in the
discord or leave them in the comments
section below the sponsor of today's
podcast is
algo algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company
with software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stockouts reduce
returns and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai
that drives smart ioi headed by a bright
individual by the name of amjad hussein
another supporter of the podcast is
brilliant
you can subscribe to brilliant.org toe
t-o-e
if you'd like twenty percent off their
annual subscription and i'll be speaking
more on that
later if you'd like to hear more
conversations like this then please do
consider supporting
at patreon.com i've also recently opened
up a crypto account and a paypal account
and if you like
you can donate there i plan on having
many more conversations like this
at the end of august there's going to be
yoshibak and donald hoffman coming up
at the end of this month i'm speaking to
chris langan he's the person who has
reportedly the highest iq
in america and has a theory of
everything called the cognitive
theoretic model of the universe
there's also a discord with the link in
the description
if you'd like to discuss the topics in
this podcast or other podcast in real
time to chat with other people who are
like yourself thank you so much
and enjoy cure i like your colored
background that's very stylish
oh thank you i appreciate that
so okay so tell me just for before we
before we get
started here just give me a sense of who
your viewers are
sure sure they're generally
mathematicians and physicists as well as
amateur mathematicians and physicists
people who are interested in
consciousness as well so we'll talk a
bit about consciousness okay
so how long have you been doing this
podcast i've been doing it for almost a
year and i'm surprised that
i was super excited that it's growing
the way it is
and well just i just hope people
continue to be interested in those
intellectual things when they're not
locked at home with a pandemic
yeah that's right that's right if i look
around
it's i'm just focused on you i have
notes here i'm when i think i always
don't worry about it don't worry about
it okay you won't distract me
great great great i think that the
ingeniousness of
steven a view of what you've done is
difficult to overstate
with regard to the tools you provided
mathematicians and engineers
physicists you've
not only provided concrete computational
tools but also
i don't know if you've heard of this
concept called psychotechnologies
the language is a psychotechnology it's
what changes the way that you
communicate and think
and it's a good time i haven't heard
that term so that's an interesting
though
great sounds a little bit sinister
though
well i don't intend to be sinister it is
important to give people
frameworks to think within but uh uh
yeah much of the critiques that i've
read of yours are ad hominins they're
not from people who have
read your work and i find that
frustrating because as i'm researching
firstly just so you know i've gone
through the jonathan gerrard archive
papers
almost each of them as well as your
bulletins and it's so
tricky at least i find it frustrating
because people who are commenting on you
are commenting at an extremely high
level
at what they perceive you're doing or
what they perceive you think
you're doing with what you're doing and
i'm curious if you get frustrated as
well
one one feature of uh you know
i do what i do because i'm interested in
doing what i do so to speak
i'm not really doing it because i'm you
know
trying to convince other people that
what we're doing is incredibly clever or
whatever
and you know so the the the kind of
if i had spent my life kind of saying
what do other people think about what
i'm doing
i wouldn't have done most of the things
i've ever done and
i think as a matter of fact the thing
that's been
actually a surprise to me is
how very positive so many people
particularly in the physics community
are being about the project that we're
doing you know
it's a surprise partly because 20 years
ago
when i released my new kind of science
book
it's uh you know i'm enough of a student
of the history of science that i kind of
understand a little bit about what
happens when
when paradigm shifts when sort of
changes of thinking occur
and one is absolutely should expect
that uh the the benign thing that
happens is people just keep doing what
they were doing before and they
completely ignore whatever the new
paradigm is
the less benign thing is people get out
their pitchforks
and they say we don't want a new
paradigm we're you know
go away we just want to keep doing what
we've been doing and what i found when
when the new kind of science book came
out 20 years ago
in pretty much every field other than
fundamental physics
people were like oh this is kind of
interesting you know we don't mind
having a new paradigm we've
you know we're they're uh or maybe they
said we don't care but mostly they were
most
fields it was like this idea of using
computation as a foundation for modeling
this seems interesting this seems like
something we should explore
and they did the one place where that
was um where it was a lot of pitchforks
um was a little strange to me because
you know i
used to be a professional theoretical
physicist so to speak so
i you know i i knew that crowd of people
um
and it was a bit surprising to me you
know i i said to many of them
i'm surprised you care why do you care
so much
and they were like because what you're
doing is going to destroy all the stuff
we've been doing and it's like i don't
think so
you know if we're doing something it's
complementary to what's what's being
done elsewhere
not uh not something that at
cross-purposes so okay
so 20 years goes by and now uh
for a whole variety of reasons not the
least uh being uh
jonathan gorad and and max piskanhofen
and other people
sort of saying yes we'll we'll help you
actually push this thing forward
um i get started on the project again
two things
surprised me first thing is that the new
paradigm that that we've kind of
built out is much more
uh sort of much more
not complementary but much more uh kind
of supportive
of a lot of existing mathematical
physics than i had expected
that's one thing that's an intellectual
thing the biggest surprise is
the sociological response has been
basically positive
um and uh you know it's it's not a
trivial thing to introduce something
which is sort of a
a significant change of a bunch of ideas
in a field
and have people feel like yes that's a
good thing it's
it's uh it's something that people can
get behind so i'm sure there's all kinds
of coping about all kinds of things
and i have to say i'm pretty pretty uh
it's
it's completely invisible to me i don't
read it i don't know what's there
i don't really care it's um you know i
think one thing to realize about
about my kind of activities
is from my point of view one of the
things that i get
you know personally most fulfilled by is
thinking that the things that i build
whether they're
practical technological tools whether
they're ideas
are things other people have fun with to
me for whatever reason of you know
personal peculiarity or whatever i like
that that's
like that's that's really nice i i like
feeling that way
i also recognize that you know any time
one has
a degree of visibility in the world one
becomes kind of
a thing that gets battered around by
people of like look you know i can use
this person as an example of this point
that i'm making about this or
you know look i i you know i need to
hate this person because
this and that and the other you know
because it makes me look good for this
group of people or whatever it is who
knows what
you know that's what you sign up for um
if you're doing things that have
visibility in the world
and as far as i'm concerned you know
it's it's uh
insofar as i'm kind of the the mascot of
or the anti-mascot for this or that
thing
it's like okay that's fine it has very
little to do with me so to speak
um so i would say that the thing that's
been interesting is
is uh uh you know
there's been a lot there are a lot of
fields now where there's a pretty good
uh sort of back and forth connection
between the things that we've been doing
with our physics project
and the kinds of uh often quite
sophisticated mathematical
physics that people have been developing
in those areas and as far as i'm
concerned that's
that's really cool i mean it's really
nice it's i i really
excited that people in these fields
sometimes their fields which have been
a little bit marooned because they've
been or a little bit sort of
adrift because they're fields where
there's a lot of interesting
mathematical structure
but they don't really know how it
connects to the real world so to speak
and now we're giving them a way to
connect and often and giving them a way
to understand
why their mathematical structure is more
natural than they thought and so on
and i think for me personally the uh the
fact that
people in those fields are excited about
this that's really cool i really like
that
um so but perhaps i didn't since i
didn't hear all the words of the
question you asked maybe i wasn't
answering them i'm not used to this
particular recording mechanism so
uh that can't be absolutely certain but
it looks right
why don't you give a three-minute
synopsis i know that's difficult
as to your theory for those who are
unacquainted
well gosh so i've been working on this
for like 40 years so it's a little bit
hard to compress but
but i suppose as gradually as one learns
more about what one's talking about
it becomes easier to explain all right
let's
talk about physics and kind of um
what's the universe made of so to speak
and
i think one of the things that has been
the the first question is
uh we think about things like space and
time
and the traditional view of something
like space has been
it's this thing that you put things in
it
it isn't a thing itself it's just sort
of a background
and you get to specify a position here
or there in space that's been kind of
the idea of space
since uh euclid and so on so
one of the the basic points in uh
kind of the the models that we've
developed is
uh there's something space is made of
something
just like a fluid like water you might
think of it as just a continuous fluid
where you can like
uh put something anywhere in the fluid
actually you can't
it's made of discreet molecules bouncing
around and and so we think it is with
space
that uh sort of at the lowest level at
very small scales
space is just made of a whole collection
of discrete elements we can think of
them as like geometrical points
but they're not points that have a known
position
in anything they're just discrete
elements and the only thing we know
about those elements is how they're
connected to other elements so it's kind
of like
the the the points since that exists
in the universe are sort of friends with
other points and we build up this whole
network
of connections between points and so
our our universe as it is today might
have maybe 10 to the 400
of these uh of these sort of atoms of
space
that make it up so sort of the first
point is
everything in the universe is just space
so
what uh all of the particles and
electrons and quarks and all those kinds
of things they're all
just features of this details of the
connections between these
atoms of space so sort of the first
thing is what's the universe made of
it's made of space what space made of
space is made of this
giant network of of nodes giant network
of discrete elements
and we don't even from that no wire
space three-dimensional that the thing
could be connected any way at once
what happens is that on a large scale
something which is
discretely connected like that can
behave as if it is for example a
three-dimensional manifold
on a large scale and and for example one
thing that can happen and we think does
happen in the early universe
is that the universe goes from being
essentially an infinite dimensional
uh network where things are everything
sort of connected to everything else
to this sort of more or less
three-dimensional so far as we know
right now
perfectly three-dimensional though we
suspect there are some dimension
fluctuations
um that exists today so okay so that's
sort of what space
is then what's time well
the the the point is the idea is that
there are these definite rules
that will say if there's a piece of
network that looks like this
transform it into one that looks like
that and that's continually happening
throughout this
this network that represents uh the
structure of space
and the content of the universe and so
what's what
um uh what we're what we're seeing then
is a sort of progression
of all of these little updates of this
network that represents space
and that progress of all those updates
corresponds to the progress of time
and one of the things that's unusual
about that is for the last hundred years
or so in physics people have kind of
assumed space and time is sort of
the same kind of thing one knows about
relativity one knows that sort of
there's
there's processes that kind of trade off
space with time yet in our theory
space is this extension of this this as
it is turns out to be a
hyper graph this network basically and
time
is the progressive sort of inexorable
computation
of the next configuration of the network
based on rewriting the previous
configuration
so one of the things that is sort of an
early thing to realize in our models
is this question of of so how does
things how does something like
relativity arise
well the answer is if you are an entity
embedded within this network
it turns out that the only thing you are
ever sensitive to is kind of the
the the network of causal relationships
between
updating events and it turns out there's
a few more steps here but
it turns out that uh with uh with
certain conditions on the way those
updatings work
it is the case that uh uh
basically special relativity comes out
of that we can talk in more detail about
how that works
so the next thing that happens is this
the space
just made up from this network it's sort
of the the the the continuum limit of
this network in the sense it's like
you've got these atoms of space
underneath and then a large scale space
is like kind of a fluid made up of lots
of atoms
um that uh behaves in the continuous way
that we're
used to to perceiving it and then it
turns out
that you can get space in any other
dimensions you can get space with
different kinds of curvature
one of the big results is that you can
get uh the the the way the curvature
arises in space
is exactly the way that einstein's
equations for gravity
say curvature should arise roughly
energy momentum
mass these are all associated with
levels of activity in the network
and roughly levels of activity in the
network produce curvature in the network
in just the way that einstein's
equations say that uh
energy momentum in in physical
space-time should produce curvature in
in space
so that's that's a pretty important
thing i actually knew that back in the
1990s that these models
um could uh reproduce general relativity
reproduce einstein's equations
so then the next big sort of pillar of
20th century physics is quantum
mechanics
they're really literally probably two or
maybe three pillars of 20th century
physics
general relativity the theory of gravity
uh quantum mechanics
and also to some extent statistical
mechanics
which also uh sort of comes out from the
formalism of these models but it's
maybe it's not the first thing to
explain here
but um so how does quantum mechanics
arise well first thing is what is
quantum mechanics what is the
what is the important feature of quantum
mechanics basically
in classical physics before the 1920s or
so
people thought that in physics there
were definite equations of motion
things behave in definite ways you throw
a ball it goes in a definite trajectory
when what quantum mechanics says is no
that doesn't isn't what happens
instead there are many possible
histories that develop and
the the universe has many possible
histories and all we get to be sensitive
to
is some kind of aggregated probability
of what happens
not knowing specifically what the
history of the universe is
well it turns out in our models that's
something that inevitably works that way
and um what happens is we're talking
about sort of the rewriting of this big
network
and the point is that there isn't just
one
possible rewrite that happens at any
given time there are many possible
rewrites
and each of those different possible
rewrites represents
essentially taking the universe in a
different path of history
but the critical fact is that just as
there are
there might be two possible rewrites
that could happen and they produce a
branching
of two parts of history so also it will
turn out when there are other
rewritings that can happen later that
actually these branches can merge so you
end up with something
which is this whole graph of possible
histories we call it a multi-way graph
and in this multi-way graph there is
both branching and merging of histories
and that uh that process of branching
and merging of histories
that ends up being the story of quantum
mechanics basically
and one of the things that sort of a
thing to to think about is
when we look at they have this whole
multi-way graph of all these branching
histories of the universe
and we say let's let's imagine that we
are observing that
we are uh it's a little bit hard to
imagine because
what's happening is we our brains our
minds
are the are themselves embedded in this
multi-way
graph so just as the universe is
breaking into all these different
parts of history so too are our brains
breaking into all these different parts
of history
so in a sense what's happening is it's a
branching brain observing a branching
universe
you have to kind of think about what is
how do you how do you kind of
how does a how does the brain how does
our mind make sense of
that universe and what you realize is
that you're kind of defining what we
might call reference frames
kind of quantum reference frames they're
analogous to the reference frames that
we think about in relativity where
reference frames typical inertial frames
are things like you are at rest you're
traveling at a certain velocity
et cetera et cetera et cetera there's
kind of a quantum analog of those and
that's
the way that we perceive this multi-way
graph of possible histories
and so when we say let's pick a
particular quantum reference frame
uh corresponds to more or less a
particular time
um and that let's then ask
what is the sort of slice of this
multi-way graph
defined by this quantum reference frame
what we have is
all these different possible histories
and they're all kind of laid out
in some sense histories can be close to
each other if they had common ancestors
recently
histories could be further away from
each other if they didn't have a common
ancestor for a long time and so on
all these histories are kind of laid out
in some kind of space we call that
branchial space the space of branches
the space of quantum branches
and that branchial space it's not like
physical space it's not like something
where
you have ordinary motion from one place
to another
but in branchial space um there is it's
it's a layout of possible histories of
the uh possible states of the universe
effectively
so one of the things that i find really
neat
is that you can talk about motion in
physical space you can talk about
uh for example uh you know even ever
since newton we've we've kind of had
this
principle that if things aren't acted on
by a force they will keep going in a
state of uniform motion
so it's kind of like things go in
straight lines if you leave them by
themselves
and kind of einstein's big idea in
general artillery was to think that yes
things do go in
kind of straight lines in the sense that
their shortest paths geodesic paths
but space can be curved and then what
might be to the thing kind of its
straight line path to the outside
is a curved path and because that
curvature
is associated with energy momentum that
is what
leads to the effect of gravity so to
speak so physical space that's how
things work
turns out in branch shield space they
work in essentially exactly the same way
except now in terms of the equations of
gravity
we have uh the equations of quantum
mechanics and quantum field theory
um and essentially what's happening is
that there are sort of paths in
branchial space that are being followed
and we are seeing deflections of those
paths actually associated also
with energy momentum and the way those
deflections work
uh exactly gives one the path integral
of quantum mechanics
so the the thing that's really pretty
neat is
i mean one of many very neat things but
one thing that i
just found uh really was a very wow
moment about a year and a bit ago now
gosh you can't believe it so long
um the uh congratulations by the way
it's
um uh yeah well time time inexorably
moves forward right so
it's it's um no but i think the the um
uh
that you know sort of a wow moment was
realizing that that the einstein
equations in physical space
are basically the same thing as the
feynman path integral
in bronchial space so in a sense general
relativity and quantum mechanics
are the same theory just played out in
these different kinds of space
and uh that has a lot of implications
because it kind of shows one
how there are correspondences between
general relativity and quantum
and quantum mechanics and the sort of
the sort of uh
i don't know intersectional cases uh
when one's dealing with black holes and
so on but but so that's a that's at
least
one level of um uh the story of our
models of physics
and um uh you know there's a lot of
detail a lot of things that are now
it's now clear yes we really can
reproduce exactly what happens in you
know
black hole mergers we can reproduce what
happens in quantum computing
we can reproduce all these other kinds
of things and we're starting to have
kind of ideas about uh you know a lot of
i know a lot of experimental physicists
who keep on saying to me when are you
going to give us actual experiments to
do
and we're getting closer you know it's
no point in telling them
there's a lot of actual physics and
astrophysics and so on to be done
to work out exactly what to look for but
i mean another direction here that that
uh is well there's several directions i
mean one is
kind of understanding um
i've had sort of in the last few months
kind of a deeper understanding
of uh what kind of observers of the
universe we actually
are and how consciousness relates to
what kinds of things we do and don't
observe about the universe and what
consequences that has
for the kinds of laws the kinds of
physical laws that we believe are going
on in the universe
that's one direction another direction
is
trying to understand if we can say yes
we have this simple rule that's updating
this hypergraph and so on and then you
say
why is it that simple rule not another
one what i've realized
recently what we realized a while ago
but it's become
a lot crisper now is this idea
that actually there is the um in some
sense the universe can be running all
possible rules
and we are we are seeing some kind of
reference frame not in
physical space or in branchial space but
in this thing we call rule space the
space of all possible rules
we are essentially picking a particular
description language a particular
reference frame
with which to understand the universe
and so the sort of paradox of why or
this
this sort of conundrum of why does one
why does the universe follow one
particular rule and not others
turns out the answer is it follows all
possible rules and we are just
at some place in rulial space observing
it in a particular way
and that has the big surprise to me
recently last month or so
has been realizing that i actually think
we can get a serious answer to a
question like why does the universe
exist
and as a matter of fact the thing that
comes out of that is
the realization that as soon as we say
the universe exists
and as soon as we give that argument we
are forced into a position that
mathematics
in some sense fundamentally exists too
which is something you know people like
plato have said but
something very different from the way
that people have uh uh
assumed the foundations of mathematics
work so you asked me for a three minute
i'm sure that wasn't three minutes but
um
summary but that's uh i mean i i have
not talked about a lot of the
intuitional
underpinnings that are necessary for
this theory of physics
concepts like the principle of
computational equivalence computational
irreducibility and so on i mean
what's basically happened in the
building of this this theory
is uh it's sort of the result of well
it's i guess it's now
40 years of my uh activities
um that in the first of the first layer
is probably
you know i i used to do sort of
traditional
quantum field theory general relativity
particle physics kinds of things so i
i know that stuff fairly well although
although it's
kind of it's a a rip van winkle type
situation for me because that was 40
years ago
and i'm right now kind of um it's it
hasn't changed as much as you might have
thought a field might change like if i
look at
biology over that period of time you
know there were all these things in
biology where it's like i learned stuff
about cells 40 years ago 45 years ago
whatever
and it was like that's an organelle of
unknown function
and now there's a whole you know vast
journals devoted to exactly what you
know the golgi complex does or something
something like this so so in a sense
that field has advanced a lot more than
physics over that period of time
but i think um the uh you know sort of
that layer then there's the layer that
i've spent
years building practical technology for
actually
computing things and uh both
the the level of understanding of how
formal systems work
that has come with the process of
designing wolfram language and
mathematica and so on
that has been really critical to what we
built and then the very practicalities
of
you know so we actually have an
environment in which to do experiments
we can you know do graph theory easily
and things like this
and then the whole new kind of science
development
of what simple programs do understanding
principles of that and so on and i
realized there's a
there's in the end a fairly tall tower
that we've ended up relying on
uh to uh uh to kind of construct
this theory and i you know to me is this
funny feeling because
you know i'm i'm really excited that we
managed to
get this done and it's gone a lot better
than i expected it would go
but it almost didn't happen i mean it
very very nearly didn't happen
and you know the question that i might
ask myself is
if it hadn't happened when would it have
happened otherwise
and the answer is i don't know 50 years
100 years
i don't know it wasn't it wasn't a thing
where
you know it wasn't like all the stars
were lined up for everybody so to speak
it was a particular
series of things that are kind of the
story of my life and then people like
jonathan who had their own
uh things that they bring into this um
you know
it's kind of a an unexpected and unusual
alignment
plus it turned out we managed to get a
lot further than we ever expected to get
so it's some uh anyway that's that's a
little bit of an outline of
of um kind of
where we are i suppose i mean there's
there's a lot more to say about the
details of what's happening with the
models and and how we compute things
from them and so on but
you ask for a basic introduction that's
my attempt to the basic introduction
what's the difference between the causal
graph and the multi-way graph
is one a transitive reduction of the
other are they the same
no no they're different kinds of things
so
so you have this prop
okay so that there are many kinds of
graphs oh look there we go there's a
nice
this is a multi-way or a causal that's a
causal graph that that thing is a causal
graph
so okay sorry there are a lot of kinds
of graphs running around
that's right that's fine and each one of
these nodes represents a hypergraph in
and of itself and then these lines
represent updating rules that's
that's a causal graph so that that's a
no each one of those nodes represents an
event
an updating event so what happens is
okay let's let's go through the kinds of
graphs
so first kind of graph is the spatial
hypograph
that represents the structure of space
its
nodes are atoms of space its hyperedges
are relations between atoms of space
okay and at any moment in time
you can imagine that you've taken a
slice
representing the current moment in time
there is a spatial hypergraph that
represents the structure of the universe
okay so that's first first level of
graph the second thing is
that graph then evolves and it evolves
by events that take a particular
set of hyper edges combine them together
and produce another set of hyper edges
or another some set of atoms of space
that produces another set of atoms of
space
so it's like a you're running all these
little functions you've got you've got
this
uh this spatial hypograph and it's got
all these all this it's like a big data
structure
with lots of um lots of pieces in it
and they're these functions that are
running on particular parts of that data
structure to produce
uh new uh pieces of a new data structure
every update event that's an event so
the causal graph
is the network of causal relationships
between those updating events
so why are there why are those updating
events connected
well the reason they're connected is
because a particular updating event
needs something
as input it needs to use certain
hyperedges certain atoms of space as its
input
and the question is are those hyperedges
up to date
do they have those and so there's a a
set of causal relationships between
these updating events where one updating
event
can uh it has it is it has a
it has a causal dependence on a previous
updating event
so you get this this graph that connects
that represents the causal relationships
between updating events
that's a directed graph uh if you go
from one event
and you follow its arrows you're
basically going into events that are in
the future
so those arrows represent a time-like
path
just following those arrows is a
possible time-like path
so you can also ask two events
could they happen at the same time so
there are events that couldn't possibly
happen at the same time because they are
they're in a chain one following from
another in a timeline
sequence so those couldn't possibly
happen at the same time
there's no reference frame there's no
assignment of simultaneity
which will allow those things to happen
at the same time so what what can occur
is that but in this it's a partially
ordered set
of updating events and in that post set
there are things where you can have
two updating events which can be
considered to happen at the same time
you can have a reference frame
where those two updating events could
happen happen
you say they happen at the same time you
couldn't do that if they were in a chain
one after the other
but you can do that if they're in what
in post-set language is an anti-chain
yeah a doodle correspond to the
different lines that are separating
which i imagine they're separating into
quote-unquote branches of space
possible that's a possible foliation of
that causal graph so what that means is
that that is a possible choice of what
updating events should be considered
simultaneous
to what other ones and just like in
relativity theory
there are multiple different possible
foliations of space-time
so there are multiple different uh
choices of what you consider to be
simultaneous so to speak
um and that uh that's the um
so the causal graph okay the the
the ordinary causal graph is the network
of causal relationships
between updating events in
space or in space time now
okay so that's that's one level of graph
the other
the next thing that we can talk about is
the multi-way graph
and then not to sound too confusing but
there's
also a multi-way causal graph um ah ah
okay okay
and the multi-way causal graph is just
so you know stephen i
i read virtually each one of the archive
papers and for some reason this
is a sticking point for me what's the
causal graph versus the multi-way graph
are they the same while they're defined
in the same document so it'd be unlikely
i i wrote this kind of technical
introduction to our project where i have
an appendix
that simply lists all the different
kinds of graphs because i knew people
and one of the things that was you know
there's a practicality of doing a big
project like this
you know there was a funny moment when
we did the colors
for all these graphs because what we
realized is you know you're just drawing
all these graphs and you see one of
these graphs and it's like
what on earth is this and we realized if
we have consistent coloring of these
different graphs
at least as soon as you see a graph you
say i mean we kind of joke that there's
this
color we call branchial pink which is
the color of our branchial graphs which
is yet another kind of we haven't even
talked about yet
um but uh you know the the um uh
the causal graph we have you know the
events are in yellow
the edges are in brown the spatial graph
it's all sort of blue
um and the multi-way graph well let's
talk about the multi-way graph
so the multi-way graph in the simplest
form
the nodes of the multi-way graph are
complete states of the universe
so the paths in the multi-way graph
correspond to
possible histories for the whole
universe
um now that's what we might call the
global multi-way graph
um there's been a big effort max
piskanov has been the main one
sort of pushing this to have these
things we can call local multi-way
graphs
they're hard to understand but they're
important and they will help us to
understand quantum field theory a lot
but they just uh they're there but the
global multi-way graph
every node is a complete state of the
universe
and so so then
the multi-way causal graph is asking
of those complete states of the universe
what are the causal relationships
between
uh between those those states of the
universe
and that gives us the multi-way causal
graph and the the ordinary multi-way
of the ordinary causal graph is a is a
is a kind of a slice
of the multi-way causal graph so the
multi-way causal graph
represents the set of causal
relationships including
both things that could happen at
different places in space
and things that can happen on different
branches of history so
one talks about events being time-like
separated that is one
they follow from each other in time
another possibility is that they're
space-like separated
that is those events correspond could
correspond to the same time
but they are separated in space there's
a third possibility which is they can be
branch-like separated
which means that they're occurring on
different branches of quantum history
and so there's all three of those time
like separation space like separation
branch-like separation
in the multi-way causal graph all three
kinds of separation occur
and um the the question of which one
uh you know any two events can be both
space-like separated and branch-like
separated
or they can be just branch-like
separated and so on and
that's a that object the multi-wave
causal graph
okay so for the spatial hypograph we
believe that it's continuum limit when
you look at a large number of nodes
is like ordinary spaces like a manifold
it's like um
uh for the uh for the multi
for the ordinary causal graph it's the
same kind of thing it's like a minkowski
space it's like
the space you probably know that that
ordinary
you know something like euclidean space
has this feature
that you can move one way you can move
back you know every
every path you can go down you can you
can reverse it and go the other way
right that's a feature of ordinary space
i can move this way i can move that way
um in space time that's not how it works
we get to go forwards in time we don't
get to go backwards in time
and so that corresponds to the limit the
limiting structure is not euclidean
space but a minkowski space
and so that's the same kind of thing
with our causal graph
the limiting structure is a minkowski
signature space
that is it can be in general a curved
space just like in general relativity
the multi-way causal graph we don't
understand very well yet what its
continuum limit is
it's a it's a weird kind of minkowski
like hilbert space
interesting and um it it a special case
of it is probably twister space
which is um uh this idea that's this
kind of neat
trick with complex numbers that roger
penrose invented back in the 1960s
as a way to understand um uh well to
think about sort of quantum mechanics
and space time and so on
but it's it's a that seems to be a
special case of the multi-way causal
graph but there's a
there needs to be a generalization of
that made to be able to um
uh to see how to um to see what that
continuum limit looks like
and and we can keep going and it's
things get wilder i mean we start
talking about some
oh well i mean the the yeah i mean there
are a lot of kinds of graphs running
around here
does causal invariance apply to one of
the graphs not the others or all the
graphs
causal variance is a feature of causal
graphs and
what it is telling you is that well
it's also a feature of multi-way graphs
let me be specific there's the condition
placed of causal invariance is that one
placed on the causal graph or is that
one placed on the multi-way graph
it applies to both it has it has
consequences for both of them they're
different consequences
the consequence of the multi-way graph
is it implies that in a simple
sense in simple sense which isn't
completely correct it says
every time there's a branch there's also
a merge
every every time the the the the the
pods of history diverge they will also
converge in the future
now it isn't that's confluence correct
that's confluence that's right okay
the and and causal and variance is a
generalization of that that also applies
to the infinite time case
right okay so one of the conditions for
causal or causal invariance implies
global
confluence what else is necessary
for causal invariance so one of the
conditions is global confluence
yes i mean it's its own separate
condition i mean it's a
it's a condition what it implies is that
the multi-way causal graph
breaks down into a whole collection of
individual non-multi-way single-way
causal graphs that is given a particular
branch of history
there is a a a causal graph and that
causal graph is independent of the
of the microscopic order of updates so
in other words
the whole idea of causal variance which
was sort of a concept that i
i came up with in the in the 1990s um
was um uh this idea of okay so
you have all these updates and you can
say well what order should i do these
updates in
okay and you can looked at from the
outside of the system
you do these updates in different orders
you'll get different results
the the interesting fact is when certain
properties hold
the causal graph not the individual
sequence of updatings that you can
change the order of those
but the causal graph that connects those
different updates that gives the causal
relationships between those updates
that is the same for systems that are
causal invariant that's the importance
of causal and variance
is that the causal graph remains the
same and that's what pretty directly
leads to special relativity
so it's a feature of uh that's
that's a feature that the causal graph
is a unique
causal graph it could be the case that
as you do different updating orders for
things
that you end up with different causal
graphs but you don't
and and so that's the feature of causal
invariance
that gives you a unique causal graph and
that's why
sort of played in the in the relativity
situation
that's why different choices of
reference frames give you the same
physics that's the sort of underlying
cause of that
of that effect now you know what we've
understood in more recently
is causal variance can be an effective
causal invariance
that can be a kind of trickle-down
effect from
something much more uh
well again it's kind of complicated
because this is a an idea of jonathan's
is sort of to induce causal invariants
through what are called completions in
the
uh in the multi-way graph and um
in any case one of the things that i
think is becoming clear
is that that we had thought
oh there are all these possible rules
only some of them will be causal
invariant
but it turns out that by the time we're
looking at kind of the trickle down
from this uh sort of universal possible
rules
there is an inevitable effect of causal
invariance there
so we we don't have to worry about oh
can we find a particular rule
that has these causal variance features
this this is a bit complicated and i'm
skipping
many steps and talking about this but
i'm trying to give a sense that
that causal variance which we had
thought was a kind of a special property
it's like you know be a prime number
rather than just be a number
it's kind of inevitable the level of
causal variance needed is sort of an
inevitable consequence
of this sort of trickle down from
thinking about all possible rules for
the universe
this is a detail but never mind this
never mind this
um what are you what i haven't seen much
of an exploration of in the archive
papers is rulial space and that could
just be because
i haven't read the right ones okay so so
i i wrote
one uh piece about rule space
investigating a particular example of it
for touring machines
um and uh you know it's a very junior
version of the universe so to speak to
imagine the universe is just a turing
machine
so you know turing it just has this tape
where
there's uh symbols written on the tape
ones or zeros for example
and there's the turing machine has this
head that's walking up and down the
tape and um according to fixed
rules so
an ordinary turing machine just has a
fixed set of rules so it sees
a particular symbol on the tape it looks
up its sort of table for what it should
do
it moves the left or the right it writes
a different symbol on the tape
that's what an ordinary turing machine
does you can also have a multi-way
turing machine
where just like all these other
multi-way systems instead of it doing a
definite thing at every step
it has multiple things that it can do at
each step and so that
you then end up getting this multi-way
graph of possible histories of turing
machines
yeah okay so then what you can do is you
can say well let me consider all
possible touring machines
interesting so that then is rulial space
that's a that's
in this particular example with this
particular coordination that is a rule
space of turing machines
where you're looking at the maximally uh
sort of non-deterministic turing machine
the turing machine
that where it can do any possible thing
um and that so
so one of the things that is interesting
is you might say
well if it can do any possible thing how
come there's any structure to the space
the reason there's a structure to the
space is the following you're saying i'm
starting off all possible touring
machines
and they do all possible things but the
point is that
two turing machines that start the same
and then branch into two different
states
it can be the case that those turing
machines can also merge that is those
two different states
can both end up uh
being being transformed to the same
state so
that phenomenon that when you have many
possible states
and you apply many possible rules
you can end up with something where
there's sort of this entanglement
between states
induced by the use of these rules so in
a sense it's this
it's the fact that identical states
merge
that leads to a kind of entanglement in
this multi-way graph
and that's what makes rural space
non-trivial
and so then the question is what is this
limit
of um uh
you know when you have when you have
this limit of of all possible
rules being applied what is the thing
you get from this limit of all possible
rules being applied
and that object is this rule multi-way
graph
and uh that's that's kind of the the
object that represents kind of the
universal possible
universes so to speak so i mean these
are this this gets fairly abstract and
it's it's you know you can understand
this
i mean the the uh um
there's a whole kind of world of higher
category theory and so on
which provides a framework for thinking
about these kinds of things that i think
is useful
i think a bunch has been done it's one
of these places of sort of mathematical
physics mathematics kind of area
where um you know a lot has been built
and it turns out that um um
the um um uh
a lot that has been built turns out to
be useful for our project
you know i'm extremely impressed with
this model
both it's its simplicity and his power
i don't like to give my opinions usually
when i'm interviewing someone because
the audience doesn't particularly care
about what i think
and in some ways it detracts but i
i find i find plenty of it to be fun
in the sense that there are these
elemental elements these novelties
then you're wondering well okay so we
have these hyper graphs we have updating
rules and so on
and we have our laws of physics okay how
can this limit to that
and i imagine much of the working
sessions i've only watched a couple
imagine them
that they're quite enjoyable oh yeah
i do this because it's fun i mean it's
as simple as that but but
you know one thing i would like to say
about this you've got a model over here
you've got physics that we know over
here
one of the things that is an important
kind of intuitional thing to realize is
don't reverse engineer from the physics
we think we know
that is a tremendous tendency of people
to do that and it's a tremendous you
know we know all this stuff
so let's figure out that must mean that
underneath it is this this and this
that's not how this was built this was
given this
you know very simple framework what
consequences does it have
now is it going to intersect with actual
physics or did we just miss completely
and is this a model of nothing in
particular the
you know it's very important that you
build up from the simple
model and then you see where you build
and it so happens that the amazing thing
that was really the big surprise of a
year and a bit ago
is you know the thing we built is
physics basically
and that's the thing that was that was
sort of the big surprise it might not
have been
you know as it's turning out okay i now
realize
and i sh that i should have realized
years ago that it's sort of inevitable
that this has to be physics but that
wasn't obvious to me
as we were building it and it's it's the
thing that's been
really interesting to me is the
realization that not only is it a model
of physics
it's also a model of a whole bunch of
other things and
that you know i have the experience with
cellular automata that i worked on for
many years
so cellular automata are just these
extremely simple programs
where you just have a line of cells
let's say each one is either black or
white
and then a series of steps you update
the color of a cell according to the
color of the cell above it and to its
left and right let's say
you might have thought that a simple
rule like that would always lead to
simple patterns of behavior
but the big discovery that i made in the
early 1980s is that that's not true
that you can get very complicated
behavior even from very simple rules
and the thing that happened with
cellular automata is they're very
minimal models
they're just you have a line of cells or
you have a a array of cells or whatever
and you're applying these local rules
and you're updating the thing very
minimal model
so then you roll the clock forward a few
decades
and you realize oh gosh there are models
that use cellular automata for zillions
of different things
from you know road traffic flow to you
know
the way leaves work to the way that um
i don't know catalysts and and camera
and surfaces work
to the way all kinds of different things
all kinds of to mollusk pigmentation
patterns whatever
all kinds of different things and so in
a sense you have this very minimal model
which in that particular case assumes a
certain structure of space and time but
you have a very minimal model
and that model ends up being a model of
lots of kinds of things so in a sense
it's unsurprising
that this much more flexible model that
we have
that we built for physics ends up
looking like it's going to be a really i
mean you know very
powerful model for the foundations of a
whole bunch of other fields as well
and the thing that's really interesting
about that is you know so i've been
doing a whole bunch of work on meta
mathematics
the kind of overall structure of
mathematics where where the nodes
are not atoms of space but the nodes are
mathematical theorems
and the relationships between them are
proofs of one theorem from another
well you might say what does that what
on earth does that have to do with the
structure of the physical universe
but it turns out that it looks like the
the formalistic structure of that
is the same as the structure of the
physical universe
and that's um that's something that's uh
both
uh it's it's a it's both surprising and
the most important thing for me is
it means that you get to have this kind
of cross-connection
of the ideas from metamathematics and
the ideas from physics
so in physics we've learned a lot of
stuff about how general relativity works
how all these kinds of things work so
now we get to import those ideas
into meta mathematics and we get to
import the ideas of mathematical logic
into physics and so by realizing that
the underlying formalism is the same
we get to make that kind of uh
conversion and this formalism also seems
to be
uh really the right formalism to think
about distributed computing
it may very well be the right formalism
to think about systems biology
and it uh the the one that i've been
poking at a lot recently is economics
and it may well be the right formalism
to think about that in each of these
applications
the details of of what the corresponding
what the thing that's like the atoms of
spaces
are different and the details of how it
works is different
but the point is that the overall
structure the overall formalism
seems to carry over and that allows you
to use sort of big ideas from one field
in another field
so that's that's been uh you know it's
it's a it's a more global theory
than i ever imagined it could possibly
be and and i've realized that um
the you know the fundamental uh sort of
struggle
in a sense for these theories is the
following you have a simple rule
underneath but that simple rule just
like in my cellular automata
the simple rule leads to very
complicated behavior but it leads to
behavior that is
computationally irreducible in the sense
it's complicated enough
you can't tell what's going to happen
without basically just running the rule
and seeing what happens
so then the thing which i should have
been able to figure out
but didn't is in assume that there's a
simple underlying rule for the universe
there's computational irreducibility
that produces immense complexity in the
behavior of the universe
how come we can figure out anything
about the universe
how come we can even say the universe
follows definite laws
how come we can predict what's going to
happen at all why isn't it just a whole
mass of irreducibility and what you
realize is
within any computational irreducible
system there are always these pockets of
reduceability
there are always pockets yeah there are
always pockets of reducibility it's it's
so there is no way to construct the
system that's computationally
irreducible that has no pockets of
reducibility
i believe that to be correct okay but i
mean there
no i mean that's a to
fully formalize that notion would be
quite interesting i suspect that you can
get some formalization through speed up
theorems in in computation theory
but um i think it's it is intuitively
fairly obvious
but if as you try and nail it down um uh
there will be you know i think the speed
up theorems are the way to think about
that
in a somewhat more formal way but um
so in any case the the um uh the thing
that one realizes is
so there are these pockets of
reducibility that exists
and the thing that is sort of the the
big surprise is
those pockets correspond to the big
theories of physics
each one has probed some pocket now the
next question is
are there other pockets that have never
been discovered that are
theories of physics that we just don't
know that are complete
global theories like general somebody
like quantum mechanics
but we don't know them and what i
realized recently is
that the the kind of the the
you know the reason that we know those
theories
is because there are certain attributes
that we as observers of the universe
have
and those attributes lead us to those
theories so
the attributes are things like that we
have a computationally bounded
way of understanding the universe now
that's one of them
another one is that we have a definite
thread of experience in time
we we are we are not operating with many
many many threads of experience we have
a definite
sort of thread of consciousness that we
follow we're not um
uh and that and in fact the thing i
realized just in the last week actually
um is uh uh
one of the things that is non-trivial in
our models is the notion of
uh maintaining your identity so to speak
so in this hypergraph
every every atom of space is being
destroyed a new one is being
created all the time so the question is
how come you and me
seem like we sort of exist through time
turns out
our atoms of space are being destroyed
and recreated
you know whatever it is 10 to 100 times
per second
so in other words how come we are a
thing we maintain our identity
that is a non-trivial fact about us as
observers
that we we we consider ourselves to
maintain our identity
and through time the thing i realized
just recently is there's a similar
way in which we do that in space it is
not obvious that there would be a pure
notion of motion
that is that you could move you know as
i move from here to there
the atoms of space that are in me are
different
and right yet me i have an identity
that i think i can carry around i can
carry it through time
i carry it around in space the
assumption
that i maintain that identity is
what ends up being sort of a tail that
wags eventually that gives us the laws
of physics that we know
in other words if we did not have that
assumption about ourselves
we would have different laws of physics
and if we didn't have
for example the the notion that
oh i don't know this quantum
measurements occur the notion that we
we collapse all these different parts of
history into a single definite outcome
that is directly related to the fact
that
we imagine that we maintain a definite
identity through time
that in other words if if we just said
oh i don't care about that
i'm not going to maintain a definite
identity through time i'm perfectly
happy to have myself
branched a zillion times
then you no longer get this idea
that we imagine about quantum mechanics
that there are somewhat there are
definite outcomes that occur
so in other words it's it's our our
way of constructing ourselves and the
way we think about ourselves
and the way we kind of perceive the
universe that drives the structure of
the laws of physics that
that we know so one of the things that
that obviously leads to
is well maybe there are completely other
laws of physics and a completely other
sort of plane of existence
that we are utterly unfamiliar with and
i think that's
almost undeniably the case that that
exists
and that's probably one of the reasons
why you know when you say what about
other intelligence in the universe why
haven't we met all the aliens and so on
well because actually their
sort of perception of the universe may
be so different from ours
it's kind of incoherently different and
it's not something where
our our narrative about how the universe
works
kind of carries over to those those
those kinds of uh
places so it's it's a it's in a sense
it's a rather humbling
experience because you're realizing that
that you know all the stuff we built in
physics and so on
is all we built it because that's the
way that we
parse the universe so to speak and were
we to parse the universe differently
we would have completely different views
of physics um
and i mean i think the thing that has
been well this is this week's issue
is thinking about that in terms of
mathematics
insofar as we believe that there is this
kind of object
that represents the mathematics of all
possible mathematicses
and that we are merely as mathematicians
so to speak
we are merely observers observing some
slice of that object
what is the what is the analog of the
constraints of consciousness and the
physical world
on the on sort of what is a mathematical
consciousness so to speak that's my
that's my that's my personal homework
exercise for the week
um that's interesting so this
consciousness that we have isn't
necessarily that
we can't communicate with any other
being because
the laws of physics that they perceive
is incoherent do they perceive coherent
laws
yes i think so i think so i mean but the
way you think about it is this
in this kind of rulial space different
points in rule space
correspond to different description
languages for the universe
so just like in physical space
we have a view of the universe that's
based on the fact that we're sitting on
the earth
you know which is in some corner of some
galaxy that's in some corner of the
universe we have a point of view on the
universe based on where we are in
physical space
so similarly in rule space we have a
point of view on the universe that's
based on where we are in rural space
now the question that we can ask is just
like we can ask for the
extraterrestrials
do they live in alpha centauri or do
they live in you know
25 light years away or whatever where do
they live in physical space relative to
us
we can also ask the question whether
they live in rural space relative to us
we've not mapped out rule space nearly
as well as we mapped out physical space
so we don't really have a good sense of
those um those distances and those
what that corresponds to but that's kind
of the way to think about it and i i
would love to know
you know how close is the nearest
civilization
in rural space people say you know let's
go check out the stars
you know the nearby stars and you know
look at the ones with exoplanets and
things like that
and uh you know but there's a different
question which is
kind of in in rural space what's the
closest
you know what's the closest thing we can
recognize so to speak
and i don't know the answer to this and
that's some
uh but i think to the observer
themselves
i think it is almost tautological that
things will seem coherent
so for example to do an exercise let's
consider two
intelligences that aren't us okay so one
that i'm always fond of mentioning is
you know the weather has a mind of its
own
it has you know it's doing these
sophisticated computations
but it doesn't have this kind of single
thread of consciousness type thing i
mean we have
in our brains we have actual you know
structures in our brains
that lead us to have this sort of single
thread of attention
that kind of sequentializes all of our
experiences
and when you know when people sort of
lose that
they become unconscious so to speak and
and you know we've got
you can still have plenty of neurons
firing in your brain but not have
consciousness
you don't have this integration of of
kind of the single thread of experience
and the weather is sort of a bit like
that it's got lots of not neurons but
it's got lots of
fluid processes sort of firing all over
the planet
and but it doesn't seem to have any kind
of sort of single thread of experience
that's going on
so that's sort of an example of and if
we say can we communicate with the
weather
well not any way that we know i mean we
we we have something where it's sort of
an
incoherently different experience of the
universe
than the one we have now if we put
ourselves
in the mindset of the weather does it
have a coherent view of what's going on
to itself probably tautologically yes
um maybe a better example that's maybe a
little bit closer at hand which i have
not thought through completely
is sort of distributed ais so
in other words you've got an ai but it
isn't just one ai it's a whole network
of computers
and it's like what is its experience of
the
of the world and what physics does it
imagine is going on because
for example you've got all these
different ais they've got all these
sensors
and they're seeing things that happen
those sensors
might be separated by distances that are
quite large compared to
you know that takes significant time to
for signals to travel between them you
know what is its view of the universe so
to speak
it's very different from ours because
we're we're localized at a particular
point in space
um etc so it's kind of a good exercise
to try and think through in fact i was
i was sort of trying to inventory and i
i think it's a great
setup for a a piece of science fiction
more difficult than i can
than i can certainly muster which is
imagine all these different scenarios
imagine you are
an organism that spans a galaxy
how does the universe look to you
imagine you're an organism
that routinely ends up on different
sides of the event horizons of black
holes
what does the universe look to you
imagine you're an organism
so to speak that lives on photons that's
associated with photons
you know where basically no time has
passed
from the last scattering surface a few
hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe and now
if you're a photon so it's kind of like
what are these different views of the
universe that you have
if you are uh implemented in different
ways
and you know there are probably uh sort
of implementation levels for the
universe
that involve kind of just recognizing
different features
of this whole network of atoms of space
and so on completely different from the
ones that we recognize
in um you know in our analysis of of the
structure of
of the universe so i mean that that's um
uh anyway that that's that's kind of my
um
um uh my way of thinking about this
it seems like there are two issues here
about extraterrestrial life or
intelligent life
one is whether or not we can communicate
with them and the other is that we can
perceive them
so when we're saying that we don't see
extraterrestrial life the argument
you've given seems to be that we can't
communicate or be extremely unlikely
that we'd be able to communicate
with it if we were to encounter it but
does that mean that we can't perceive it
we can see
for example a whirlpool or a hurricane
whether or not we can communicate with
it is another issue
so i mean the first step is there's a
level where we don't even see it because
it's it's it's features of the structure
of space that we are simply not paying
any attention to
you know there there's some detail it's
like like for example
one of my guesses about you know i like
to think about
you know i like to think about history
of science i like to think about how did
people make mistakes in the past
how were things that became obvious
later not seen before
and so a question about today's sciences
what
is there in today's science that people
will say i can't believe
that they didn't see this and i'll give
you an example one that i suspect is is
one of those
so you look at a gas it's got a bunch of
molecules bouncing around
we say the gas has certain pressure it
has a certain temperature
but all those details about all the gas
molecules bouncing around
we just say that's entropy there's no
there's no detail there that we care
about it's just random
that's probably wrong there's probably
another
you know whole pile of other properties
that we should be thinking about there
but we're just not paying attention to
so to speak
and so that's that's an example of of a
place where
sort of the extraterrestrials could be
all around us
and we just wouldn't know it because
they are
sort of their civilization so to speak
lives in
features of space that we are simply not
paying attention to
so that's one possibility another
possibility is
uh yes there are
things that we can perceive
but they just don't make any sense to us
it isn't it doesn't
uh you know it's like um uh like the
weather for example
where it doesn't uh it
it makes i mean you know it makes no
sense
we don't have you know what would you
talk to the weather about you know what
is its experience
in order to you know what do we talk to
animals about well
not a lot really because you know
there's certain emotional
kind of commonality that we have with
animals at some level but mostly
we can't really have a a philosophical
discussion with your average bear so to
speak
um and uh the i think the reason
uh you know that that's something that
it it isn't you know there's a separate
level of issue
of sort of the the um uh sort of this
this um
beyond just perceiving that the thing is
out there it's like why is it doing what
it's doing do we have a story about why
it's doing what it's doing
do you know if we don't have any such
understanding and even across time
for for our own species you know you
look at archaeological remains
from a few thousand years ago it's like
what on earth were they thinking we have
no idea
you know what would be our
communications it might we might be you
know we
put ourselves down a time machine which
i don't think can exist but anyway
imagine it
um you know and when we say uh to some
the the to some um um you know
person from 3000 years ago uh you know
what are you doing
oh they give a whole explanation about
you know they're pleasing the gods by
doing this thing that does this that
does that
and it's like what the heck are you
talking about you know we have no common
uh framework for thinking about these
kinds of things
um so i think that that's you know the
the level
at which communication is possible is is
pretty it's pretty narrow
is there a way in which this entire
hypergraph or our entire
universe is conscious much like you
mentioned we can have consciousness or
different
into alien intelligence running through
us in an ether that we can't interact
with either because
computationally irreducible so we can't
we don't discern it
or because well because
whatever reason so so yes i mean
okay there are sort of
there's intelligence there's
consciousness i think they're somewhat
different
so intelligent in any definition of that
that is a generalization beyond the
purely human
i think in in any reasonable definition
one would say the universe is
intelligent
it is yes it is okay the now
conscious it's a little bit more tricky
because it seems that consciousness is
actually a step down
from intelligence that is you can be you
know all those individual neurons all
those
like our immune system might be
something that is doing computations as
sophisticated as our brains for all we
we can tell the immune system is you
know has all these complicated
interactions between cells and so on
but yet there's something a little
different about the way the computations
that our brains do
from from the ones our immune system
does or that seems to be
and one of the differences is that we
have this
notion of a single thread of experience
and that's a feature of of the kind of
thing that our brains do
that isn't an immediate feature of the
way that
our um the way that these other
computational processes
that sort of seem like that that have
intelligent like behavior
it's not a feature of those so
consciousness i i have come to think
is a step down from intelligence
consciousness is a specific
uh sort of a specific
thing that gets added on top of
intelligence that is
sort of this the single thread of time
story
and also this computational boundedness
but that kind of
that's kind of a necessary thing but
it's it's this it's this idea of a
single thread of time i think
is is sort of a critical feature of that
adds kind of um uh that's the layer that
adds consciousness so does the universe
have that
not really the universe doesn't have
that in fact the universe
in our models it's got all these atoms
of space that are doing all these things
all over the universe
there's no single thread of time there's
no single thread of experience
lots of different things are happening
all over the universe lots of different
space-like separated things are
happening lots of different branch-like
separated things are happening
so there isn't that single thread type
type experience
so i think in that sense i would i would
say that in that what seems to be the
appropriate definition of consciousness
the appropriate generalization of
consciousness beyond the merely human
wouldn't encompass the universe um
intelligence would encompass the
universe consciousness would not
you mentioned photons not having an
experience of time in your model do you
have a conceptualization of photons
because it seems like there's different
time steps and time is just the
inelectable
sequence of updating so what's a photon
is it one that goes
well we're not sure yet completely
but um uh
the possibility of something moving at
the speed of light the speed of light is
defined in our models
by you have one event and you say how
many other
events does that event lead to that's
the light cone
of uh of what you produce and so photons
have to live on the
uh at least close to the the edges of
that light cone
and so that's that's sort of what tells
us something about
the kind of structures that photons
correspond to we don't know exactly what
they are yet
i think the thing that one can realize
is
this notion about time passing versus
distance gone
if you are an entity within our system
you have you are you are using
computation
to progress so to speak and you can use
that computation if you're just sitting
still
all that computation gets used to
actually move you forward in time
all that computation gets used to figure
out the next
configuration that you have in time if
you're also moving
some of that computation has to be used
up in recomputing
what you're like at a different place in
space that's interesting that's
basically what leads to time dilation
and relativity
is that you're trading off the use of
uh you know you're trading off the
computation used for motion
with the computation used for time
evolution so if you are
if you have motion then you get to use
less of that computation for time
evolution
and time effectively runs more slowly um
and so for photons
there's probably there's there's
presumably an extreme version of that
but we don't understand the details of
that yet
when it comes to real space there's a
quote i believe i took it from
one of your papers it says the principle
of computational equivalence implies a
fixed maximum speed row
in rule space now is this principle
taken as an axiom or is it derived
and and how exactly do you derive that
maximum speed
without that axiom or can you okay
so the epistemology of science is more
complicated than people often give it
credit for
the principle of computational
equivalence is
it has a complicated epistemological
status
somewhat similar to the second law of
thermodynamics somewhat similar to
things like the church touring thesis
they're all the same kind of thing
so the second law of thermodynamics is
both a definition of heat
and a statement about how systems in the
universe tend to work
and a mathematically provable thing it
is both
all of those things are none of those
things so in other words
the principle of computational
equivalence if you
is something for which we actually have
good
evidence that is the principle of
computational equivalence basically says
if you have a system that operates
according to rules
if the behavior that you see is not
obviously simple
the the behavior will correspond to a
computation that is as sophisticated as
anything
that's the basic statement so it implies
that
your average thing even though its rules
may be simple so long as its behavior
isn't obviously simple
will tend to be for example computation
universal
to interrupt sorry what do you mean by
isn't obviously simple
so can you give me an example of
something that is
computationally inequivalent yeah yeah
right so so
repetitive behavior is obviously simple
nested fractal behavior is obviously
simple
it's things where we can readily predict
where we can use a much simpler
computation
to jump ahead where we can say uh
you know you've shown me a few steps now
i know what's going to happen
i can predict a billion steps in the
future what's going to happen now all of
these concepts
there so so that's what it means to be
computationally
that that's what it means to be not uh
you know to to be to not seem like it
has complicated behavior
now as you start trying to i mean
the thing that's interesting about all
of these principles
is that as you start trying to put
stakes in the ground of what does this
precisely mathematically mean
you realize that the thing is
it ends up being you know the principle
of computational equivalence
is at some level an abstract fact about
some
about rules it's an abstract fact
um and it can be proved at least in
certain examples as an abstract fact
but you might say that thing over there
i can i don't see how it's simple
so it must be computationally as
sophisticated as anything
but then somebody can say oh you missed
this particular way in which it was
simple
so you know and that's why it isn't as
computationally sophisticated
but then you can say that sort of
tautological because if
if it's computationally sophisticated
that's basically the statement that it
doesn't have any simple way to work out
what it does so
it's it's the the thing that's important
about principle of computational
equivalence is that it is a
a conceptual framework for thinking
about how things work that is people had
the idea
including me that you have simple rules
you'll have simple behavior
it's not true and this principle tells
you that it is maximally not true
in other words whenever it seems like it
might not be the case that the behavior
is simple
it really isn't and it is sort of as
sophisticated as you can possibly get
so the the um with respect to speed in
royal space
that assumption of a maximum upper limit
i think you could derive it
yeah you could derive the upper limit
from the church touring thesis
which is a a sort of subset of the
principle of computational equivalence
so that so i mean that particular thing
is
is not doesn't need pce i think i mean i
think it needs um
uh to derive the upper limit what what
what is not obvious is that the typical
light cone
will have a surface that is like that in
royal space
that needs pce so what it's saying is
the church touring thesis would say
that there exists things that go as fast
as
that but not faster what pce says is
your average light cone in rural space
will in fact expand at that speed
um that's interesting so so okay so that
then
that maximum speed of of um
uh
so the maximum speed in royal space
is essentially telling you something
about the actual
raw processing power of the universe
it's telling you
um i mean it's i was i think i'd written
somewhere in a
in kind of you could you could take it
in any kind of computational units but
you can say
you know number of wolfram language
tokens processed per second
is by the universe it's kind of one one
way of of measuring that
something we realized recently is that
um coarse graining
that is the process of not looking at
every detail but looking only at a large
scale which you use in statistical
mechanics and so on
um course screening in rule space
is making a higher level description
language
so in other words you can make a
description language that's really at
the lowest level
where you're actually describing how
every everything works or you can have a
higher level language
which describes only more in in sort of
higher level terms what's going on
what's the relationship between
computational irreducibility and
undecidability general undecidability so
um also the relationship between the
reducibility and the
principle of computational equivalence
does one require the other can you
imagine a world with one but not the
other
so principle of computational
equivalence implies computational
releasability
and and basically they're really locked
together
because what happens is you have a
system
it's computing what it's going to do
next you are an observer of that system
you're trying to predict what it's going
to do next
the question is can you jump ahead of it
and figure out what it's going to do
sort of more efficiently than it does
itself
principle of computational equivalence
says you sorry you're stuck being just
computationally equivalent to the system
and that's what leads to computational
irreducibility
undecidability is an infinite time limit
of computational irreducibility
computational irreducibility
is a if you say what's the system going
to do
in the end after an infinite amount of
time
the answer uh can be
well in order if it's computationally
irreducible the only way to find that
out is to wait for a potentially
infinite amount of time
so if you say i really want to know in
finite time what's the system going to
do
the answer is sorry it's computationally
irreducible
the only way to know that infinite time
answer is to wait an infinite time
so that that's the reason that um so
those uh you know
computational irreducibility implies
undecidability
um could undecidability exist
uh um
i don't think so i think it might be uh
associated with
some things called intermediate degrees
which are an idea that you can have a
system which has
undecidability without computational
universality which i tend to think is
is not really it's not a real thing it's
a it's something people
imagine can happen in systems but i
don't think it will actually end up
happening
it's something where you can construct
examples which are kind of special put
up jobs where you essentially have a
universal computer inside
but you've chopped off all its input
output mechanisms
enough that it can't act as a universal
computer but can still have
undecidability and i
don't think that's a i don't think
that's a real real thing
but um uh yeah so so those are
undecidability is infinite time limits
of irreducibility basically
speaking of what's real or what's not
real is infinity
real who's infinity i mean
the the you know look the the
you can write down you know in wolfram
language there's a symbol infinity
that represents infinity and one over it
is zero and you can say lots of things
about it
if you want to ask the question can i
make an infinite
um can i sort of actualize infinity
that's this is a complicated question
because you can
certain kinds of infinities can be just
made symbolic and reasoned in terms of
to explicitly make infinity is a
different thing
than to reason in terms of infinity you
know we can write down
trans-finite numbers and we can do all
kinds of reasoning about transfinite
numbers
that doesn't mean we can explicitly in
our universe
make a birthday cake that's a
trans-finite number so to speak
i mean we we can't um so the question of
actualization in the universe versus
symbolic representation is a little bit
of a tricky question
okay forget about us making infinity is
there a quality of the universe that's
infinite at all so for example infinite
space
infinite computational speed infinite
memory storage
and and how can we enter even if there
was an infinite
is there a way that we could tell is
there an experiment
that would let us know that infinity
exists in some way shape or form
or is it somehow irreducible it would
look like noise to us
well i think we can wait for an infinite
time we'll know in the infinite future
we'll know if the universe is infinite
i mean i i think that before that we can
um you know the
the question for example is space uh
you know infinitely divisible that would
be a question we might ask
um i think
our models look like they're going to
make some very specific predictions
about what happens in
fast rotating black holes and things
like this where
they will kind of see through there'll
be a microscope that kind of sees
through down to the actual fabric of
space time
and actually sees these discrete things
and were we to be able to use that
microscope and work to see
you know where to just keep seeing you
know finer and finer and finer detail
you know in other words we look through
a physical microscope and
we're used to seeing oh you know the
biological organism actually is made of
cells oh
you know we look it's actually made of
molecules the molecules made our atoms
the atoms are made of whatever
you know and the question is space right
now we might
think our microscope for space we just
look and it keeps on looking the same
it's always indivisible you know it's
always it's always divisible
and the question is what we're saying in
this theory
is no at some point you'll see the atoms
of space now you don't really get to do
that
because you are embedded your microscope
is made of the same atoms of space so
you don't really get to make a
microscope
that directly sees that so you have to
use more indirect techniques
to be able to kind of sense the presence
of these atoms of space
but you could certainly imagine
something where
uh you know you could you could predict
we don't know what scale precisely these
atoms of space occur
but um where you're kind of trying to um
uh you you're sort of making the
universe
be in in such an extreme condition that
you kind of see through to the structure
of space
it's very similar if you're going
through a fluid
you know a typical you know a car going
through air
doesn't know air is made of molecules it
just knows there's a flow of air
a hypersonic plane missile or something
going through air
absolutely does know that air is made of
molecules of oxygen and nitrogen and so
on
because at that speed you've kind of
broken down
this continuum structure of space
in that case of a fluid of the air
you've broken down the continuum
structure of the air
and you are sensitive to the presence of
individual molecules with particular
properties
and so the question is can we find
extreme situations in space-time for
example
where we're similarly sensitive to the
underlying structure
of of space and you know there's a
decent chance that we may have examples
of that
usually when talking about whether or
not space is discretized or on a lattice
in some way
people say well we have these fluids and
then as you
investigate further you find out that
they're atoms and we thought that they
were continuous
but then as you investigate the atoms
further you'll you find out that they're
quantum fields
and obviously then you can say well
those quantum fields are discretized
do you think that there's a place in
your models
for continuity underneath
what seems like discrete points so
let me be a little bit more specific
anything that i can think of as
continuous there's some way maybe
a simplicial decomposition to make it
discrete but then also the same you can
apply step functions of a certain
width from something continuous to make
something discrete
so when someone says well this is
obviously discrete well
the argument can can be turned on itself
the thing to understand
the formalism of our models is probably
most
humanly stated in terms of hypographs
and things like that but it is
basically certainly the case that there
are for example algebraic formulations
of what we're doing
in fact some of the things from category
theory look that way
where you can think about it as features
of some continuous space
you know it is you know some algebraic
geometry feature of some continuous
space etc etc etc
the net result is it's just the same as
this hypergraph
but it is presented as something that
looks like
you know topological uh you know aspects
of the homotopies of
continuous spaces or something but it
looks like
but but a different interpretation is
that it's just this hypogolf
so there's nothing particularly special
about this hypergraph except that it's
the most human
relatable version of what's going on
i'll give you an analogy
in theory of computation you can think
about lambda calculus you can think
about combinators you can think about
register machines
or you can think about turing machines
turing machines are the
you know at least in the early such
systems where the most human relatable
you know way of thinking about
computation and i think that there are
different formulations of our models
that uh some of them we can see now some
of them will probably emerge in the
future
that look different with respect to that
now there's a more extreme possibility
which i don't know if it's the case and
i'm trying to not
repeat mistakes of history so to speak
here you know when einstein invented
general artillery
one of the things that uh came up was
the theory as he
first set it up implied that the
universe expands
and he was like that can't possibly be
right you know
surely that isn't right so let me add
this extra cosmological term
to uh to prevent the cosmological
constant and so on to prevent
the universe from expanding well turned
out
it was true that the universe expanded
and he shouldn't worry too much about it
well in our models the most obvious
possibility
is that this uh hypograph
is progressively subdividing itself it's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
um and the the distance
one meter is corresponding to more and
more and more
sort of separate atoms of space if you
lined them up and looked at their
connections and so on it will be a
larger number of connections that would
have to be made
to correspond to a meter of physical
space so one thing which i have to say
it does
look in these models is if it's
suggesting it's the way it happens
is that in fact the amount of the number
of atoms of space is
rapidly increasing in the history of the
universe
and if that's the case one of the most
bizarre possibilities
is you say okay you say i've got an
experiment it's going to test whether
the universe is discrete
as i run the experiment the universe is
subdividing itself
so if the experiment said i'm going to
test is the universe discrete at the
level of 10 to the minus 200 meters by
the time that experiment has been run
the universe will have subdivided itself
to be 210 to
10 to the minus 220 meters or something
and so in other words it will always be
running away from you
it will always be subdividing itself
faster than you can painted subdivision
it's kind of like the ultimate epsilon
delta proof in in calculus or something
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is
facility with mathematics as well as
discernment of the underlying physical
laws and
you may think that this is beyond you
but that's false brilliance provides
pelucid explanations of abstruse
phenomenon such as
quantum computing general relativity and
even group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su 2
cross su 3
that's group theory for example now this
isn't just for neophytes either
for example i have a degree in math and
physics and i still found
some of the intuitions given in these
lessons to vastly aid my penetration
into these subjects for example
electricity and magnetism sign up today
at brilliant.org
tow that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20
off the annual premium subscription try
four of the lessons at least don't
stop before four and i think you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease at which
you comprehend subjects you previously
had trouble grocking
links are in the description is there a
way to test the discretization of space
or time
in the cosmic background radiation
because of how quickly it inflated
maybe even that inflation no maybe i
mean
we've been looking at this what what if
the universe starts infinite dimensional
um what um uh and gradually cools down
to being three-dimensional
we expect there to be some dimension
fluctuations left over
they may have survived for hundreds of
thousands of years they would lead to
perturbations in the cosmic microwave
background
um and uh that we don't yet know what
those perturbations are like we're just
trying to work out what the analog of
the standard
you know robertson walker friedman
robertson walker metric
uh for a kind of a a um a homogeneous
universe what that's like when the
dimension changes we
we don't know we did some live streams
recently actually exploring that
question
we don't know the answer yet it changed
from infinite to a finite so
infinity is real or you're saying
infinite as a standard for an extremely
large
dimensional system more like extremely
large because you can't even
make a sense of a if if you have a graph
that's sort of
completely connected there's no sense of
dimension because dimension requires
that you take limits
of larger and larger distances in the
graph but there is no
if everything's connected everything is
distance one away so there's no way to
get far away and talk about what the
large scale limit of that is
how do you get the dimension of time in
your model because i can understand
space and there's a hos door for a top
of lodge
but with growing up a ball of radius
but how do you grow a ball of radius
time it's the dimension of time defined
so time is is
multi you know time is going in this
multi-way graph so time
to begin with has in a sense
it is an assumption that is a very
consciousness
related assumption that time is one
dimensional that is
that there is a single thread of
experience is basically
saying we're going to conflate time
until it is one dimensional
that is our view of the universe as soon
as we put in these foliations
we are essentially assuming that time is
one dimensional it doesn't need to be
time can be time can be off with you
know there can be many different
uh paths many different histories of the
universe that never knit together
that the the the fact that those those
things are knitted together
is an assumption that's closely related
to kind of the generalized view of
consciousness
i don't know what you call this meta
mathematical space if it's proof space
or what but as i was imagining it
nodes on a graph and there's some
diagrammatic rewriting rules
does that mean that you can make
rigorous the notion of what
beauty is you know erdos has the book
by saying that it's a geodesic in proof
space or meta-mathematical space well i
don't know that's a good question
whether whether
whether urdosh proofs from the book is
going to be
geodesic paths in um
uh in proofs in theorem space so to
speak
my guess is not my guess is most of the
shortest proofs
will be absolutely incomprehensible to
us humans so they may be i mean i think
urdosh's view of the book
was kind of a god-given book the proofs
may be well understandable to god but
sorry the humans don't get to understand
them
i mean in other words it it the shortest
it's like the shortest algorithm for
something
is usually not a human comprehensible
algorithm
so it's a trade-off of and this is very
related to what
what a mathematical consciousness really
is
because to say it's it's following
geodesics
is probably to say it's an optimized
mathematician but not a
not something closely modeled by a human
mathematician
one time i heard you speculate and
perhaps it's not perhaps it's worked out
even farther than what i saw that
particles are black holes in branchial
space
uh maybe we'll see not not properly
worked out yet
i mean i think that black holes yeah
i mean that that's a um the relationship
between particles and black holes
is an interesting one i'm i'm you know
for for anybody younger
who's who's paying attention to this i
have to tell a story i was probably 1974
1975 i was probably
14 15 years old i go to some talk by
some fancy physicist
and um they're talking about black holes
and whatever else so i go up to this
person afterwards and i say
you know uh you know could particles be
small black holes
right the person says oh no no you don't
understand anything
it's you know they're all completely
different kinds of things
so okay now we're another 45 years later
and turns out it might actually be true
so don't listen to what the the main
moral of that is
you know if you go to the talks by the
fancy physicists and um and
uh i mean i i wasn't you know at the
time it just seemed like
the feature of black holes these no hair
theorems for black holes the fact that
black holes
have this feature that there are only
certain aspects of black holes that seem
to be visible from the outside
just seem to me as the 14 year old me or
something
as being you know that seems awfully
like
what you find with particles that there
are limited number of kinds of particles
that uh just as there are limited number
of kinds of black holes
and um turns out as i say
the main the main takeaway from that is
um uh
you know so i'm applying that to myself
so just as i
may say to somebody about some idea you
know that couldn't possibly be that way
um you know wait another few decades and
maybe it'll turn out to be right
but um what are snake states
oh this is a complicated story that and
i'm running out of time so we probably
let let's not let's not dive down that
that term i mean
even if even if that led to some
wonderful puns about snakes on a plane
and things like this
do you have any fineman stories that you
haven't told before that i haven't told
before
um or how about this you mentioned one
time
perhaps more that feynman is
misapprehended as someone who has an
extreme understanding he does
but he was great at calculation and that
calculation allowed him to understand
and perceive
apprehend what other misunderstandings
or false impressions do people have
about feynman that you're able to see
from the inside
oh the one that always drove him crazy
was um and you know you mentioned at the
beginning of uh
of this you know people sort of uh
uh ad hominem attacks that uh
that i may get which i'm blissfully
unaware of for the most part but but
um the um you know
uh uh people one of the things that
drove firemen crazy
was that people thought of him as you
know
the quintessential nice guy you know
would listen to anything et cetera et
cetera et cetera
but in fact like all of us you know
he got impatient he valued his time etc
etc etc
and so when people would kind of get
close to him and he would be like
kind of snarky with them and so on they
would say
oh my gosh you know you're supposed to
be this this wonderfully
nice you know positive person and
actually
you're kind of snarky that's terrible
that's horrible i'm i'm
i'm you know that's that's very
horrifying so so actually one of the
things he always used to tell me is
don't don't appear to be too nice
because it's actually a worse life than
um
uh uh than the other so to speak i'm not
sure that i've
intentionally taken that to heart but um
it was one of those things
but i think here's the thing that um
uh i talked a lot to dick feynman about
quantum mechanics and he would always
say
you know we don't really understand
quantum mechanics you know we can
calculate this and that
we don't really understand it we don't
have an intuitive understanding of
what's going on
it's a shame he's not still around
because i would really have had a good
time telling him about the stuff we
figured out now and it's you know one of
the things i remember
just these endless conversations about
why does thermodynamics theta minus beta
h
quantum mechanics is e to the iht why
are they both exponentials like that
why is uh and i think we now know the
answer
and it's it's pretty neat and it's um i
think that um
uh somehow
i mean another thing that we don't yet
know they'll be interesting to see how
it plays out
you know one of dick feynman's most
famous probably single most famous
invention was fyman diagrams
this way of calculating uh things in
quantum field theory
um and one of the features of feynman
diagrams is
the simple ones are pretty easy to
compute but there's this whole series of
fimin diagrams for any particular thing
and they get more and more and more
complicated
and they get unbelievably more difficult
to compute so for example right now
there's a big sort of flap
because the anomalous magnetic moment of
the muon which is computed using feynman
diagrams
there's a disagreement apparently
between the experiment and the theory
that sort of why is that the case well
you know it could be
that one of the things that happens is
these series of diagrams
we don't actually know that the ones
that we can't compute yet
are really as small as we think they are
and anyway one of the things that i
think may come out
is we may have an actual method for
doing computations in quantum field
theory
that avoids feynman diagrams and and
feynman always thought
that he thought said firemen diagrams
are a crazy idea
he would always say and um you know i i
you know i can't believe people think
you know that there's got to be a better
way to do this this is a crazy way to do
it there's got to be a better way to do
it maybe we'll have such a way
i'm not sure there's there's also hints
of of better ways that
involve the um uh the whole ads cft
uh business which is pretty closely
related i think
to correspondence between physical and
branchial space in our models so
it may end up being the same idea in the
end is there some relationship between
the holographic principle and
particles being associated with black
holes in branchial space
ads cft correspondence that's probably a
large
question you don't have time to answer
now we don't know yet i mean it looks
like
the the holographic principle is a story
of
the multi-way causal graph being able to
be projected
both in a spatial direction and in a
branchial direction
and that it's basically the same graph
but you're taking two different
projections of that graph
and the fact that it's the same graph is
why there's a holographic principle
that relates those two different
projections that's that's probably how
it's going to work out
that seems to be how it will work out um
and
and so so i mean i think what
the um but i'm you you're now having me
really
troll my memory for for um
uh i'm trying to think about
some dick feynman stories that are
related to um
i mean i'm thinking about things that we
now know
so to speak that were things that i
talked to him about
um and uh um
yeah that he would dismiss
um no i mean he always believed there
was something
funky about quantum mechanics that there
was something more to understand that it
really wasn't
that what had been done to that time
which is now
early 1980s um was just a calculational
method
wasn't a a real understanding so to
speak
i would say that um yeah okay there's
another thing i remember i talked to him
at
great length about the second law of
thermodynamics
which i finally understood in the 1990s
and uh um i remember we had a huge
argument at one point
where he was claiming that the fact that
the universe is as orderly as it is
today
is a fluctuation which i was just like
that's a
stupid thing to say our whole universe
if you say our whole universe in its
current stages of fluctuation that's not
a useful scientific theory
because you're saying with respect to
our theory everything about what exists
today
is an exception and then you don't have
a theory of what
you know of what exists today but we i
remember we had a huge argument about
this
about this topic in which we we did both
have to i
i had to agree that there was a bunch
that i didn't understand about
thermodynamics and nor did he and i
think
finally we've understood how that works
and it's a story of computational
irreducibility
and i should have been able to tell that
story actually even at that time
i just didn't wasn't um wasn't smart
enough to see that
um that connection for another probably
ten years after that
okay last fluff question has to do with
cryptocurrencies and what you see is the
future of cryptocurrencies
let me read it specifically because it
came from one of the viewers
what is the future of cryptocurrencies
this is from amjad
many ceos are buying crypto as a store
of value your thoughts on it who is
satoshi nakamoto your views on bitcoin
and proof of work algorithms versus
ethereum and proof of stake
quite a few questions when there's a
long story because we've been quite
involved in the whole crypto world
um for a variety of different reasons
but i'll tell you the thing that is most
ironic to me about the crypto world
which is back in the 1980s you know i
had this idea about computational
irreducibility the idea that you might
need to do an irreducible amount of
computation
to work certain things out i
i have some considerable reason to
believe that
that um uh
the um the creator of bitcoin um was
aware of my
work about computational irreducibility
and so the thing that is kind of
the most ironic most bizarre thing is
that
when i thought about computational
disability in the 1980s
um the um
i imagined it as this limitation on
science this
principle about something formal and
mathematical
i had no idea that decades later
there would be you know whatever it is
some number of percentage points of the
of the total energy production of the
world would be
burnt in computational irreducibility
it's an utterly bizarre
it's kind of like you you know if for
somebody like me i build
theories i build tools and then the
world goes on and eventually uses those
theories and those tools
for things that are just i mean that one
was something
so far out of left field that i couldn't
see coming that it's remarkable
that that that idea of proof work is
completely crazy i mean it's it's a
it to be fair it's it's a it's very
amusing and completely crazy
and you know i have certainly thought
about is there a way to do something
like proof of work
that generates useful computation and i
have not yet figured out how to do that
but with respect to cryptocurrency and
for example the question
why is there value in cryptocurrency you
know i had thought well to get value in
economics you have to actually be making
something in the real world
and i thought for a while you know we've
been a lot involved in computational
contracts the idea of expressing
what would otherwise be contracts
written in legalese in
in computational language because we
have kind of the unique computational
language
that can talk about the real world and
that is therefore capable of having
you know contracts about the real world
written in it
so we've done quite a bit of work on
that and i sort of imagine my belief as
a few years ago was
that when computational contracts
are the dominant form of contracts that
cryptocurrencies just become a
convenient
mechanism for uh for
sort of servicing computational
contracts but then
the question is is there intrinsic value
in a cryptocurrency
and so this relates to the question of
well why is there intrinsic value in
anything in economics
and so that relates to what is the
foundational theory of economics and so
this is something i've been thinking
about
and you know i think that the the
elementary actions in economics are
transactions
and i think that what's happening is
that this whole giant network of
transactions
why does this sound like something
what's out elsewhere well because i
think it maybe is
it's something not unlike the giant
network of updatings of this
spatial hypergraph and so on it's all
these different transactions happening
in the world
and the story ends up being that what is
value
value what is what is price for example
price is something related to
okay so so think about it this way i
i've been using this thing last few
weeks at least
you know somebody wants to buy a cookie
the person they want to buy it from
eventually wants to rent a movie
the question is is there in
a certain world where it's ai bots all
the way down
one could imagine that they arranged
this network of transactions so the
person who wants to buy the cookie
eventually is giving value to the person
who wants to rent the movie they barter
everything
so that's what happens no money is
involved it's just
bought to bot transactions right so the
question is what is money what is price
and i think what it could be thought of
as i think i i don't know if this will
really work out
that it is just like you have all these
uh
sort of interactions in space and so on
and in aggregate you can think about
them
as having certain gravitational fields
certain this that and the other certain
aggregate properties
that is a description of all of those
microscopic
microscopic processes that are going on
so i have this slight guess
that value and price
are associated with sort of an aggregate
version
of all these microscopic processes that
are going on and
the most bizarre thing is that what
leads those things to have a sort of a
a robust value is computational
irreducibility
so the absolutely bizarre possibility is
that the transactions that go on an
economic system
are sort of in aggregate
they are a whole story of computational
irreducibility and the reason that they
build up
some definite sort of uh sort of solid
sense of price
or value is because you sort of can't un
unravel that computational
irreducibility
and so in some sense the computational
irreducibility is the source
of robust value in economics and then
that in a sense the bizarre thing then
is proof-of-work
is a is a crazy sort of inner bottle
version
of that process so to speak proof of
work yes the proof of work is is ends up
being sort of the
the bottled up version of that that idea
although it's it's a it's a poor way to
to think about that and i think that the
so you know what i'm imagining is that
that the very fact that so many people
are doing things with cryptocurrencies
is almost by definition a proof that
they have
value that is it could be the case that
you say well
everybody is doing things as a
speculator which might be close to true
but even so by the time there's a
complicated enough network of
transactions
that is in a sense building you up a
real value
even though those transactions don't
happen to actuate
particularly in the in the quotes real
world i mean this is
you know for somebody like me who builds
sort of a model of of the
universe that is in a sense a nice
abstract model one's asking
is there a fundamental difference
between the processes that are going on
in this purely abstract cryptocurrency
and in something that is connected to
the real world and buying cookies and so
on in the real world
and the answer is i'm increasingly
coming to the belief that there is a
a notion of a store of value that
doesn't have to do with
uh sort of the the details of that now
as a practical matter you know what's
going to happen with
with all those cryptocurrencies you know
i have no idea
you know i we've been involved with the
cryptocurrency world
so you know at this point i am the the
proud owner of a certain amount of
cryptocurrency
and um you know it's been interesting
for me because i've i've never done
uh you know our technology over language
and mathematica and so on
get widely used by quant finance people
um but i've i've never personally done
kind of um uh you know trading of of
of those things on any kind of serious
kind of actual
uh trading screens type basis and so
you know it's kind of it's kind of a
funny thing because you know i have a
company with lots of people in it but
in the end you know we we've gotten
cryptocurrency from from a bunch of
companies that we work with and it's
like what do we do with this
cryptocurrency my
my long time cfo was like you can't you
know we can't accept this cryptocurrency
what the heck are we going to do with it
and
you know how do we account for it in so
anyway we finally solved those problems
but
but um so i have been um uh i did have
an amusing time
a few weeks ago when i was was both um
uh spending some number of hours working
on the question of why does the universe
exist
and multitasking between that and
cryptocurrency trading
and that was kind of a an interesting um
interesting personal experience
you were actively trading crypto what's
that we're just you're actively trading
crypto
yes because i because we got a bunch of
cryptocurrency and
we uh you know my calculation is
by the time it's uh well the real
problem was
that within my company it was like who
do we delegate the cryptocurrency
trading to
and generally the the general principle
of companies is
you know the ceo it starts with the ceo
and then they try and find somebody to
delegate it to
and if you know we have about 800 people
but you know if none of them
was kind of volunteering i'm going to be
the cryptocurrency trader
it kind of sticks with the ceo but but i
was also just interested to get some
intuitive feeling for it um which i
think i do have now a better feeling for
um but it was just a from a purely
personal point of view the
the um the couple of days that i i
happen to spend sort of um
uh uh multitasking between figuring out
why the universe exists and figuring out
um
how we should move this or that between
cryptocurrencies was uh was an
interesting um
experience let's say um i would say that
the uh
uh you know we're actually we have all
the all the apparatus in orphan language
to build some very fancy analytics for
understanding what happens with
cryptocurrencies and we are we're just
starting to do that
and um you know it's so deeply analogous
to what's happened in quant
quantitative finance it's um i think
it's
uh uh you know the question of
of is there going to be some store of
value in the world that isn't
gold and isn't fiat currency the answer
is presumably yes
unless governments get so freaked out
about it they managed to
to to sort of smash it um i think that
the uh
you know is it good for the world though
that's a more complicated question
um is it uh um is it something where
um you know where one can understand you
know is there some way
actually it's a good exercise you know
in this theory of economics that i'm
sort of slowly developing
there are going to be analogs of things
like time dilation
and things like the einstein equations
it's a it's a necessary feature of this
very aggregated
thing of lots of these transactions and
so then the question is well
one of the things i was joking with as
we were working on this a bit
that inflation in economics
might turn out to be bizarrely similar
to inflation
in cosmology what do you mean that
there's an analog of the einstein field
equations in economics
well you've got a whole space of
transactions right you've got all these
transactions happening
and you've got uh this question is
you've got all these transactions
happening
and one thing is to say there's a global
price
but actually that probably isn't true
you've got all these transactions
happening and they're all
interwoven in certain ways and you ask
questions like
is that space for example arbitrage
you know you go around a loop it's like
going around a loop in space-time
you go around a loop between this
transaction and it goes in time it goes
to that transaction and so on
the question of whether there is an
arbitrage opportunity becomes a question
of whether there's curvature
in this kind of economic space um and so
that's that's the beginning
i haven't worked this theory out okay so
i don't know how it's all going to work
but that's sort of the beginning of the
story
um and so that that's uh and you know
these questions about um
uh you know economic activity and and
deflection of gd6 and so on
i haven't worked all this stuff out but
i have this feeling that there may be a
correspondence
and that corresponds will be very
interesting because it allows one then
to leverage both the intuition from
finance
and the intuition from physics and merge
them together
i mean i i have a friend who's long
well-known person who's a
who's was spent a lot of time as a
trader and for him
sort of you know for me things are
functions they increase they decrease
whatever
for him everything is a put or a call
and i always have to try to remember you
know
what does he mean by put a call you know
that's just some function that is
you know some particular uh you know
payoff function as
a function of price but um uh so you
know these different intuitions that you
get in different places
um have uh uh like you know the notion
of volatility that we're very familiar
with in in the
in the financial case you know how does
that map into
fluctuations in space time in a physics
case or something i don't know
i don't know what the correspondence
will be but these are these are things
that
um um uh i think there was one other
part to that question which i perhaps
now have forgotten but
but about um uh about cryptocurrency
look i think that the
the thing that's interesting proof of
work algorithms versus ethereum
and proof of stake yeah i mean look
there are many we just actually did a
little conference about
distributed consensus which is a story
of
uh part of that story that there are a
whole collection
of different ways to come to consensus
about what has happened
and in fact what we realized is that uh
both work i did on cellular automata and
other people did on cellular automata
back a long time ago
is deeply relevant there's this uh uh
blockchain called nkn
uh that is some uh nkn needless to say
sort of rhymes with nks my new kind of
science thing
and their their system is very much
based on
kind of ideas from nks and it's based on
using
a notion of consensus that is a
distributed consensus based on graph
cellular automata
that is different from the the sort of
the the proof-of-work proof-of-stake
type approach
so it's a their variety of differences
that one is a i think
a rather interesting one that uh some
other people are trying to do as well
but
nkn is probably the most um uh the sort
of most broadly deployed version of that
um i think that the um uh that's an
example of
of um um i mean
the thing that the thing to realize
about about blockchain
is computation general idea
they're different form factors they're
different workflows in which computation
is used
what's happening in blockchain is
autonomous computation
that's what computational contracts will
be there they are
purely autonomous computation that no
human initiated it
it wasn't you know it's not it isn't
just living in a cloud it's
living in a way where where something
might happen in the real world
that actuates what ends up being a giant
chain of events in the kind of uh
in the sort of blockchain world and this
kind of autonomous computation
is you know it's kind of the ai's
takeover type scenario because it's
basically
you know you end up with these giant
chains of autonomous computations
and that's an interesting situation to
try to understand
and there are a lot of things that you
know something like an nft is a very
simple kind of uh
thing about autonomous computation but
there are vastly more complex versions
of that
and we're only at the very very early
stages of understanding
sort of what's possible in this in this
world of autonomous computation i think
the thing maybe i can
can end with is the the statement that
um uh
you know in in just as all these um
all these sort of interactions in
between atoms of space
to kind of what knit together the
structure of space i think these
transactions and economics are what kind
of knit together
the economic system and lead to sort of
coherence
in things like prices and economic
systems and it's kind of interesting to
see
uh what um you know when you have a a
fork
in a blockchain it's like an event
horizon in uh
in physical space time and uh and when
you have you know these closed
uh closed countries and not
next few months available something i'm
i'm uh you know for me it's always some
uh it's a crazy thing because you know
i work in these different fields and
something like economics i've sort of
paid attention to it for decades but i
don't really
know it in great detail and um uh here i
am thinking about sort of reforming the
foundations of this field
and um it's a scary thing because it's
kind of like how much of the field
should i really know
if i start knowing too many of the
details i'm already
sunk in the mud you know it's very hard
to think
you know to stick your head out of the
mud so to speak because you're already
oh but i know that it's you know
marginal utility of this and that the
other
but at the same time you need to
familiarize yourself so how do you
strike that balance
yeah well it's a challenge right and i'm
i'm for economics i'm
i i keep on um uh sort of poking away
and i
you know i have friends who are
economists and i talk to them a bit and
and you know i'm still at the stage with
economics where
where everybody tells me something i
didn't know already eventually in most
fields that i work on
there comes this moment where most
things that i hear about are things that
i can readily fit in
to something i already know and and i'm
still still on the
still on the the upward curve with
economics but it always helps me with
that
understanding field particularly one as
complicated as economics to have
my own kind of theory about it because
then as i learn new things i have at
least a chance to fit them in to
just to a framework that i've already
built all right unfortunately i really
have to go
but um uh this has been fun lots of
interesting questions um
and um
i didn't get to perhaps 70 percent of
the questions maybe even 80 percent
maybe even more
if some of you are more familiar with
the technical aspects of wolfram's
theory
i was curious about if the global
hyperbolicity condition means that there
are no
naked singularities or is he using that
simply as a way of
foliating into spatial surfaces to solve
the
koshi problem and then to derive the
einstein equations
but he doesn't think global
hyperbolicity is actually
intrinsic to our universe it doesn't
seem like it is because
our universe is a dissider space not an
anti-deer space
if any of you can help me out with that
that would be
wonderful oh right i wanted to know if
global
confluence meant that at any two points
on this manifold
that represent our world spatially at
least
that they will necessarily causally
influence each other
at some point because he did seem to
indicate that there's an expansion of
the universe inherent in its models
but at the same time any two points are
going to be causally connected with
global confluence at least that's the
way that i see it
so if anyone here can help me out with
that either you can email me that would
be great
and while i have you here i'm curious
why you think
that there's such an adverse reaction to
steven's theories when to me
i think i'm not quite sure about that
because it is
rigorous it's not fluff
but at the same time there are also
there is also resistance to even
penrose's
ideas so at first i was thinking well
maybe you have to be a professor but
penrose is not liked by other professors
because he has outlandish ideas
with regard to consciousness and the
origins of the universe and his cyclical
model
and then there's weinstein who gets
criticized too and then there's garrett
lisi
i was wondering why there are a couple
people
one named chiara chiara marletto and
then another named sabrina gonzalez that
have their own
intriguing ideas about physics and they
don't get criticized and i'm
curious if that's because they're women
and so
academia wants to show how diverse and
equitable they are
and thus they don't criticize them
or if it's something else i'm not sure
no we didn't touch on bell's
inequalities though i believe stephen
has
see plenty of what stephen said for
example that quantum mechanics in
general relativity are
unified in that the path the way that
the formalism that leads you to the path
integral is the same that leads to the
einstein equations
they're just in different spaces as far
as i can tell that's not proven it's
just
it seems to be the case in the models or
the simulations that that they have
tested as for bell's inequality
i also don't know if steven's ideas on
that are
proven or if they're just surmising if
they're just conjectures right now
right dc atoms you can say that they're
avoiding testable predictions but that's
false because
steven isn't at all he's actively
looking for how he can
test his theory same with penrose and i
don't see any
testable or falsifiable predictions
coming from chiara or sabrina at least
not yet
but i haven't studied their models much
so it can't simply be that i don't know
why there's vitriol toward stephen eric
weinstein penrose
to some degree even julian barber but
there's not toward
chiara and sabrina is it because they're
young is it because they're women is it
because their models are just
superlative compared to
lisi garrett lisey or barber or penrose
i don't know
okay for the people watching if you want
to continue conversations
especially at a especially about
consciousness theoretical physics
and intersection between the two then
there's a discord
the discord is in the description of all
of the videos as well as
in the youtube page somewhere you can
click discord
right where there's a twitter and a
paypal and a patreon and so on there's a
discord link
join that
this channel is meant to be more of a
i know strange it's strange it's meant
to be more of a community than it is
well it's it's a mission rather than a
podcast and
i see that as what separates it and the
mission is explicating toes
and advancing toes and furthering our
understanding of the universe
it's not a podcast per se like joe rogan
or
even lex friedman where they're
interested in speaking to people and
i don't mean this in any demeaning way
because their podcasts are far
far superior to mine there's a certain
high level
at which they operate and that's because
they're interested in many different
topics and they're generally interested
in conversing with people
and i'm not particularly or this podcast
isn't about conversing in that same way
it's more about office hours is one way
that i described and i'm trying to
clarify my own thinking
but another is that we have a aim and
the aim is
the theory of everything explicating
them
because there are around 200 as far as i
can
i can count
if you would like to further that aim
then please join the discord
if anyone is watching and is
mathematically or physically inclined
when i say physically inclined i mean
mathematical physics
and you can tell me if the adm
decomposition from
wolfram's model is necessary in order
for them to derive
general relativity that's as far as i
can see it is
but at the same time so if the adm
decomposition requires you to be able to
foliate your space time into spatial
dimensions
and then sequentially move forward or
backward in time and
that doesn't seem to be what
characterizes our world
but it seems to be
essential in wolfram's models
and i'm wondering is it essential
as well as even if it is so this adm
decomposition it's
not as if that's on solid foundation
there's a
dis proof of the adm decomposition from
kirush cheva and kuzmin but
that dis proof itself is contested
okay i gotta get going i should
i should eat and i should sleep and
spend some time with my wife
if you all would like to see more
conversations like this then please
do consider going to patreon.com
i will leave a link right now every
dollar
indeed does help tremendously so here's
one
here's one way that that was invested
into this podcast i spent so much time
sitting
that i was able to get a standing desk
which is
what you're seeing right now using some
of the funds
and that i just got this recently that
helps tremendously because
my legs and my well you can understand
how a standing desk helps
so if you do want do want to see more
conversations like this
if you for whatever reason want to make
it easier on kurt
or you would like to see more podcasts
more frequently
then please do consider going to
patreon.com and donating
a dollar ten dollars fifty dollars
whatever you feel like
you can afford or you would whatever you
feel like you would like to give
thank you so much yeah grayson that's
correct
so when i asked a question that i
expected an answer that would take
three minutes it would span the length
of 10 minutes
and i'm just thinking come on steven
time is money you know this
let's let's hurry this up because i have
150 questions to get to and that's not
including the audience questions
all right everyone thank you so much for
watching and i hope that
you gleaned something positive from it
have a great night